there's no denying that Willy Wonka and
the Chocolate Factory is a childhood
classic but it's also one of the
freakiest films ever made and that's all
thanks to Gene Wilder you lose
good day sir the infamous boat scene is
widely regarded as the scariest part of
the film and none of the child actors
knew what was going to happen so when
Wilder started ranting about the Grim
Reaper the kids were legitimately scared
out of their minds and they're certainly
not showing any signs that they are
slowing even though Wilder has appeared
in tons of other iconic films it's
pretty safe to say he'll always be best
remembered for this candy-coated creep
Fest